yes or no that's the choice that Greeks
are making today a momentous decision
that so much appears to hang on people
began voting early in the morning after
a hectic and fiery campaign with the
economy on the brink of collapse Greeks
and making their voice heard I think
that we have to vote the yes because we
if we want to stay the European you know
for me it's it's absolutely necessary
nice so I'm I'm supporting very strongly
yes vote they ought to be revisiting I
voted for secrets and I'm voting no
because I've lived in Europe and I know
that other Europeans have different
rights than those Greeks Greece as an
unequal partner look down on by Europe
that's the line taken by the key player
in this drama Prime Minister Alexis
tsipras he says it's time for his
country to reject what he calls the
blackmail and humiliation of
international creditors while you were
in loud noise many people can ignore the
will of a government but no one can
ignore the will of the people to live
with determination and take their lives
in their own hands and I was fighting
talk from CRS leading a lie finance
minister Yanis varoufakis he blamed
Europe for bringing things to a head but
he said this need not be the end of the
line for relations between Athens and
Brussels this is about a holy moment a
moment of hope for the whole of Europe a
moment that gives hope to Europe that
the common currency and democracy can
truly coexist
the Greek government says a no vote will
give it a stronger hand to negotiate a
better deal with creditors but critics
say that outcome could lead to Greece
exiting the euro and what a yes vote
could mean is equally unclear yes or no
a choice with unknown consequences and
polling stations are not the only places
with queues in Athens Greeks continue to
line up at banks with cash withdrawals
limited as a momentous vote unfolds the
day-to-day grind of economic hardship
continues